pasch bin ich lange du wahrscheinlich
größer in meiner zeit der techniken alle
hallo mein name ist luca und jan sind
sich hinten
er fragte ich das gemacht habe ich war
mal wieder auf youtube unterwegs und hat
dort einen kanal entdeckt namens pro
gamer lleida programme jay und er hat
vor einem monat ein video hochgeladen
was der genannt hat trick your eyes
interviews making 45 minutes
ja das hat der hochgeladen in die
beschreibung dieses videos hat er die
sechs videos reingepackt auf die ihr
dort reagiert hat das heißt ich nehme
jetzt auch mal die videos reagiere auch
darauf und schauen wir ob er recht hat
oder nicht das erste video heißt der hat
uns die nation die apps suite
titel regeln schau im vollbildmodus
schaue immer in die mitte wenn der film
endet schnell weg okay das heute mache
das ganze jetzt mal an und jetzt wird
der screen blau was pastor dass jetzt
ihr könnt das ganze brics auch mitmachen
also schaut einfach die ganze zeit mit
mir jetzt in die mitte vom screen und
vielleicht funktioniert bei irgendwas
karan
ich habe das zu beginn so gesehen dass
irgendwie pfeile in die mitte gehen
mittlerweile sieht es für mich so aus
als wenn einfach nur so riesige fronten
keine ahnung
das verändert sich bei mir total wir
sollten immer weiter in die mitte
schauen meine damen und herren das heißt
schaut immer weiter in die mitte ich
kann es jetzt übrigens auch gar nicht so
krass schneiden weil er halt das
mitmachen könnt sag ich mal was heißt
darf jetzt nicht so viel rausschneiden
aber eher dass das sieht bei mir
mittlerweile aus wie eine sanduhr der
sand fließt aber nicht runter sondern
von links nach rechts
sorry dass ich gerade im schnitt
wahrscheinlich den ok typen eingefügt
habe aber er hat einfach perfekt als ich
mein wenn die auch bock habt das ganze
mal zu machen habe ich euch die sechs
videos einfach mal in die beschreibung
gepackt und auch das video von pro gamer
jay wo er das ganze gemacht hat also
check das auf jeden fall mal ab ich
würde gern zwischendurch mal die kämen
hier oben gucken aber irgendwie ist es
gerade viel zu befriedigen da einfach in
die mitte zu schauen
ich weiß nicht wie lange das noch geht
und ob meine augen jetzt schon enorm tot
sind quasi aber mal abwarten drehtag
mittlerweile typen
ich weiß nicht wie dieser pro gamer
james geschafft hat auch sechs solcher
videos in seinem video einzugehen aber
ich spreche allein beim erste schon
übelste kopfschmerzen die ganze zeit
okay ich mache ich hab die letzten
beiden nicht auch immer nur vier stunden
gepennt also vielleicht liegt es auch
daran ein bisschen alter musik
mittlerweile so aus als wenn die teile
die von links kommen die teile die von
rechts kommen becker und die teile die
rechts sind nach unten gehen und die
links weg aber eigentlich ist es einfach
nur verschiedene feiler die in die mitte
gehen leute ich will mal etwas was
alles bewegt sich
die tür ist keine tür mehr okay so krass
was jetzt nicht also ich habe einfach
nur weggeguckt und alles war so wir
machen wir weiter mit nächste video
optical solutions that make you think
dieses video geht vier minuten 44
verfangen direkt mal an wir müssen
direkt in die mitte wieder schauen
das ding irgendwie aus den schritt
will ich mir das nur ein oder wird der
stern immer kleiner und verschwindet
quasi in drei fehler dass die farbe oder
bin ich irgendwie hey leute das ist
einfach nur krank allein diese
videoeinblendungen gerade ist einfach
nur mega ihre fahrt wieder shrimps okay
ich glaube das ist so nett war genau das
gleiche was wir gerade als erstes hatten
aber irgendwie hat das gerade voll
alter schwede
[Musik]
das sieht aus wie sonne rutsche im
schwimmbad ohne kreide rutsche oder so
geht's ist das grün alter das sieht
genauso aus wie eine schwimme schwimmen
im wasser slave ich finde scheiß egal
ich bin jetzt schon so und wo ich bin
jetzt schon so ultra gespannt was ich
gleich sehen werde wenn ich gleich weg
gucke was
aus wie sonst ok darüber habe ich glaub
ich schon mal ein video gemacht aber
seine optical illusion dass verlinkt ich
euch mal hier irgendwo also da habe ich
schon mal darüber ein video
[Musik]
und das sieht so aus
loriot stracciatella milchshake und
jetzt habe ich da lust drauf ich weiß
ich habe der kreisel in der mitte größer
wird oder kleiner
sieht doch aus wie drei drachen die sich
irgendwie gegenseitig jagen ich weiß
nicht ob ich dumm bin oder so aber ich
sehe da drin irgendwie ab und an so
rothe laserstrahlen die aus der mitte
rausgehen alter wollte mich komplett
verarschen was was habt ihr denn alles
für optical solutions hier drin
[Musik]
aus vorbei
nichts
mir ist nichts passiert
wm ok dann starten wir das ganze einfach
mal das video geht einer minute dreißig
das sollten relativ schnell hinkriegen
ich werde das ganze jetzt einfach mal an
crd laufen lassen also wir machen das
jetzt quasi mal zusammen das heißt packt
eure schnauze eure augen auf jeden fall
in die mitte des screens also da wo
diese vier fünf balken die ganze zeit in
einander gehen und sich rotieren okay
ich glaub ich hab den ersten cut
gesetzlich gruß du hast riet opel hat
schaut immer weiter in die mitte leute
ich bin gespannt ob wir gleich irgendwas
sehen werden weil vorhin war es halt bei
mir so irgendwie das war ja gerade so
ein video wo so enormen viele optical
solutions quasi nacheinander abgespielt
wurden und ich glaube das ist nicht sinn
der ganzen sache also das ist halt
einfach dumm so wenn du so 7000
verschiedene optical solutions rheinpark
weil jeder hat er quasi irgendwie eine
andere wirkung also eigentlich muss man
sich wirklich eine für für mehrere
sekunden bzw minuten anschauen bauleute
alter ich guck die ganze zeit in die
mitte ich weiß nicht wie lange das noch
geht ich hoffe ihr kommt auch die ganze
täter irgendwann gleichkommen einfach
weggucken
und okay okay okay fachpraktische wieso
wird immer größer okay okay es ist
vorbei was war das das war bisher mit
abstand die beste optische illusion
alter ich habe gerade überall modeln
gesehen
warum tue ich mir das eigentlich die
ganze zeit an alter schwede
das läuft die ganze zeit ab hier und ich
habe das gefühl wenn man wirklich die
ganze zeit in die mitte guckt dass diese
pfeile sage ich mal von oben unten links
und rechts immer weiter in die mitte
wandern ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
wirklich der fall ist oder ob ich mir
das ein bilde aber es sieht wirklich so
aus als wenn die teile die pfeile es
lieber ich als sandy weiter in die mitte
gehen aber ich glaube dass toni sogar
oder ja doch auf jeden fall ich sagte
ich mir dass alle aber die teile gehen
wirklich in die mitte die pfeiler das
heißt wir warten jetzt mal was passiert
wenn die teile die mitte erreicht haben
die linie werden immer kleiner und jetzt
sind wieder beim start
und jetzt kommen linien raus und es ist
diesmal rechteckig es war schon die
ganze zeit rechteckig dummkopf jetzt
sieht so aus als ob ihn zuging wie oder
bahngleise während links rechts jetzt
haben wir wieder das mit den fall die
von allen seiten in die mitte wandern
wollen war und jetzt einmal wieder dass
das irgendwie so
das macht mich voll fährt
zusätzlich hatte die letzten beiden
nächte luft ich habe schon gesagt wie
viel schlaf ich hatte ich hatte echt
nicht so viel schlaf und das gerade
macht mich einfach nur müde und es mir
fällt es sei schwierig meine augen lange
aufzuhalten ich weiß nicht woran das
liegt aber meine augen fallen die ganze
zeit tun ich will mich einfach wieder
mein bett legen und schlafen dazu
bekomme ich gerade bauchschmerzen als
ich weiß gar nicht was hier abgeht nur
wegen diesen komischen videos ich frage
mich auch wenn dieses video vorbei ist
weil die class
was gerade passiert ist ich hab da
hinten 3 so teile wo sie kerzen
draufstehen und ich habe die angeguckt
und die sind eigentlich so groß und dann
auf einmal wurden die einfach so klein
ohne spaß ich hab euch dieses video der
beschreibung verlinkt das ist das vierte
video guckt sich an und macht es selbst
alter schwede ich weiß ich sehr
wahrscheinlich aus als hätte ich
irgendwas genommen oder so aber ich bin
einfach nur todes müde und das ist
gerade zehn minuten auf gegen die
optische illusion geschaut hat macht es
glaube ich nicht besser focus on the
center of the screen also leute schaut
einfach in die mitte machen wir
eigentlich schon die ganze zeit bin ich
müde wie sonnen milch shake die man
einfach nur trinken will irgendwie mit
somit zum schwarzen teilen drin oder wie
ein zebra was auf über eine rolle
gewickelt wurde die macht fertig als
wenn ich dich dumm im kopf genug wäre
kommt jetzt auch optische illusion und
müdigkeit dazu ich weiß übrigens auch
nicht ob man es ein bisschen merkt aber
ich habe mir ein paar vorhänge geholt
und die dahin gegangen dass der schall
nicht mehr so krass ist also der schal
ist immer noch da ich wollte auch noch
mal einen größeren teppich hinlegen aber
vielleicht hat sie ja schon mal ein
bisschen was gebracht
und dieses video bringt gerade nur dass
ich irgendwie dass ich irgendwie das ist
dass leute meine augen tränen nur wegen
dieser scheiße
und ich gucke weiter in die spirale
macht das schon seit drei minuten
mach es weiter denn ich will vermuten
dass ich gleich
ein hypnotischen
an fall bekomme und irgendwo
[Musik]
wow wow verschwindet lampe du bist
eigentlich größer in meinen augen zeit
der techniken an
ich schwöre ich verrate euch nicht
klickt auf die links in der beschreibung
und gebt euch dass selbst ich habe
eigentlich jetzt noch dieses sechste
video hier vorbereitet es der dezente
video for one minute aber ich meine das
sind alles sachen die wir eigentlich
schon gemacht haben also und der rabatt
aber noch ein bisschen zwischendurch und
dann hat er in eine minuten autoren
daher würde ich sagen was das mit dem
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn es getan hat und ich soll das ganz
normal machen geht man fetten like und
da gebe ich meine handynummer raus wenn
ich auf den smiley druck könnte meinen
kanal abonnieren das ist kostenlos und
verpasst kein video mehr und das ist
eigentlich relativ cool und hier findet
irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
also ist wahrscheinlich auch nice also
klickt es an vielleicht auch kacke